Today we start the Odyssey. And the
Odyssey is a sequel to the Iliad and
it's a family story. It's a story about
a homecoming. There are three main
characters, right? There's uh Odysius,
sorry,
Odysius,
who's the main character, and this why
it's called the Odyssey.
Um then there is Tanelpi who is his wife
and there's Tanakis
who is their son
[snorts]
and as we discussed when we um read the
Iliad Homer is first and foremost
concerned about the human condition.
What does it mean to be human?
What does it mean to live in a world of
war, of trauma, of tragedy, and how can
we overcome uh this adversity?
So, um the Odyssey is about three
individuals in a family and they are all
traumatized and they're all heartbroken.
Okay, so Odysius
is trying to return home from the war
and his problem is that he has PTSD,
which is post-traumatic stress order.
And this is very common for soldiers who
returned from war. They've seen so much
violence, they've seen so much tragedy,
they've seen so much senseless death
that their souls are shattered. and that
is a disease problem. Then you had
Penelope who suffering from depression
and why is she depressed? Because her
husband has been away for 20 years and
she doesn't know if he's alive or he's
dead. He's probably dead, right? It's
been 20 years. There's been no sign of
him for the past 20 years. but she
cannot bring herself to admitting that
um he's dead. So she's put herself in a
very precurious situation. There's
dozens of suitors who want her hand in
marriage and she she wants to say no,
but she's afraid that if she does that
then uh she'll be alone for the rest of
her life. But she doesn't want to say
yes because she refuses to
admit that her husband, the love of her
life, Adysius, is dead. In her heart,
she feels that he's still alive. But in
her head, she cannot justify it. She
cannot explain it. It's just a feeling
in her. Okay? And so her response, and
this what we call cognitive dissonance,
her response is just to shut down. Okay?
She just spends all her time alone in
her room.
At first, she's weaving stuff, but then
she just sits in her room, right? And
then there's Tamakus. Damakus his
problem is that his he doesn't know if
his father is dead or alive but the man
is a legend. This is a man who won the
Trojan war by coming up with a strategy
with a Trojan horse. Okay, so he is a
legend in this world and everyone sings
his praises and he's his son. So he's
living in his shadow. Okay. And he wants
to prove he's better than his father. He
wants to become a hero himself, but he's
being burdened by the legacy of his
father. The other issue is that unless
his father is dead, he cannot inherit
his father's legacy, right? His pro the
property uh the reputation cannot be
transferred to him. Then there's this
mother who's just sitting around the
house every single day. If she were to
get married, she would leave and then he
could be master of his own house, right?
But she's still around. So he's kind of
stuck. At the same time, the suitors are
waiting for Peny's answer, which is
never going to come. So they're just in
the house and they're eating up all
um his wealth. So he is just seeing his
life wither away and there's nothing he
can do about it. All right. So
um he is just depressed as well and he's
angry.
But you know all these things are the
same thing. It's really one of chronic
dissonance. It's really one of
depression. It's really one of trauma.
All right. So there's another way we can
analyze what's going on. And the thing
about the soul
and the soul is something that the
ancients
were really concerned about because it
was really the most fundamental issue of
what it means to be a human being. It's
something that we don't talk about
today, something that we don't think
about today because we live in a world
of material science. If we can't see it,
it doesn't exist. But uh for most of
humanity uh for sorry for most of human
history humanity has understood the soul
as very present and as very real and the
most significant thing in our lives.
Okay. So the soul that they understood
um let let's talk about their
understanding of the soul and this is
true for a lot actually a lot of
cultures. First of all soul um is a very
complex thing. Okay. [clears throat] It
is almost infinite dimensions.
The different layers to the soul and
there's really a part of the soul that
is you. Okay? That's just you, the
person. But who you are as a person is
ultimately influenced by other um
influences as well by other factors as
well. Okay. So these influences include
uh your family, okay, your uh culture,
the history,
um and maybe the gods, okay? So um
again, they're infinite dimensions and
these dimensions have an impact on you.
And maybe when you die, maybe there's a
part of you that lives on, okay? But
there's also parts of you that flows
back into these different streams
of the universe. Okay? So it's a very
complex thing. Now the soul um another
name for the soul that we use today
uh if you go to psychology class the
name for the soul is the world view.
[snorts]
Okay. So we have a much more simplistic
understanding of our psychology than the
ancients. The idea of the worldview is
just our understanding of who we are,
[snorts] where we came from, and our
place in the universe. Okay? It come and
we believe it comes from our memories
and our experiences.
Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> And the world view is important because
it allows us on ourselves. This is
important for things such as planning,
right? Only if you know who you are can
you actually plan ahead because then you
know what you want to do, what you want
to accomplish. Okay? It allows for
empathy,
building relationships with others.
Okay? and allows for judgment.
Basically,
[snorts]
what's good? What's bad? What do you
like? What don't you like? Okay. So, the
world view and the soul are fundamental
to who we are. Now, in psychology, what
they will teach you is that trauma
splinters the world view. Okay? There's
something about your experience that is
fundamental to your identity [snorts]
but um because it is so painful you
forget about it or you refuse to see it
and this causes a rupture in your
identity in your coherent sense of the
world which destroys your worldview.
Okay. And this leads to depression. What
is depression? Depression is the
inability
to act and to think. Okay? You don't
know what you want to accomplish. You
don't trust yourself. You don't know
what you like. And so what are the
symptoms of depression? You sleep a lot.
You find no pleasure in anything.
You feel no emotion. You feel sort of
numbness. Okay? Okay. And that's why
people they tend to take drugs or they
just sleep all the time or whatever.
Okay. All right. Because you are unable
to act. And that's exactly what's
happening to Adysius, Penelpi, and
Tamakis. All right. There's a trauma in
their lives. Okay. And they just believe
this as well. Okay. There could be a
trauma that splits the soul.
Okay? And it could be a demon. It could
be um a really painful incident. It
could be anything, okay? But it splits
your soul.
And if you are to recover, then you have
to repair your soul. And that's a
fundamental conflict and dilemma within
the Odyssey. You have three individuals,
Adysius, Penelpi, Tamakus. Their soul
has been splintered. And so they're on a
journey, their own odyssey to repair
their soul. [snorts] And the answer of
course is each other. Okay, the love for
each other. That's what's that's what's
going to save the world. Okay, the love
of family
and that is the fundamental message of
the Odyssey. All right, and that's why
it's such a powerful read.
Okay, so let me give you some background
as to the plot. So, um, as you know, the
Odyssey begins in immediate intermediate
rest. Okay, in the middle of things,
which is to say that a lot of things
have already taken place and happens
just in the middle of the plot. Okay, in
the in the in the beginning, Odysius has
been away for 20 years and he's stuck on
an island with Calypso, right? Penelpi
is depressed and cinemas
is angry. Okay, Athena comes and tells
Damascus, "Come with me. I will help you
find your father." Okay. [snorts] Um, so
[sighs]
the story starts with a Trojan war, of
course. Okay, so remember the Tro
there's the Helen has been taken to
Troy. She falls in love with Paris
because that's what Aphrodite promised
Paris as a prize.
Um and now her husband, the king of
Sparta, Mana, and her um and his brother
Egabana, the king of kings are like,
"We're going to raise an army and we're
going to get back Helen." Okay? And this
is prophesized. This is this is to be
the greatest war in human history. It
will make it will make mortals into
gods, right? That's why Achilles enters
this war because this is the opportunity
for him to prove that he is the greatest
warrior of all in all of human history
and that's why he goes to Troy. Odysius
is also
supposed to go to this war. But Adysius,
he's different from Achilles
because Adysius loves his wife Penelope
and he has a new son, six months, six
months old Tanakas. So he's conflicted
and he really doesn't want to go to war.
But the Greeks need him because the gods
have told the Greeks that it is really
Adysius who will win the war because
he's the one who will come up with the
Trojan horse, the strategium that will
win this war. So you need this guy.
Okay. So this doesn't want to go but the
Greeks insist. So the Greeks send two
messengers to uh Ithaca
um where Odysius lives. Now this is what
he does is he pretends to be mad. So he
dresses up a beggar. Okay, he's a king
but he dresses up really badly and he's
going around the farmland and throwing
salt everywhere he goes. He looks crazy.
Okay, and you throw salt in the land to
kill crops. So he looks kind of crazy,
but the but the Greeks understand that
this is a man of disguise. He's a man of
strategims. He's very clever. So it's
probably a trick. So what they do is
they take his 6mon year old son Tamakus,
okay, and put it in front of Odysius.
Odysius is plowing the field and salting
the fields, okay? And basically the test
is this. If you're really mad, you're
going to run over your son Tamakus and
kill him. If you're not mad, if you're
not really crazy, then you're going to
stop and go somewhere else and save your
son. So, so let's see if you're really
crazy. [snorts]
And so this is of course
uh turns away and saves his son and the
ha you see you're tricking us all along.
Come with us to uh Troy. And so this is
has no choice but to go. Okay. So this
is why Odysius goes. He's forced to go.
You think about it, the story doesn't
really make any sense, right? And that's
the um greatness of Homer because he's
telling us the complexity of human
psychology.
But this is really really smart. He
thinks ahead, right? He should know that
if he were to have the strategium, the
Greeks would see it see through it
really quickly, right? So what he should
be doing is hiding from the Greeks,
right? or maybe um just moving away. If
you really really don't want to go to
this war, you just run away and take
your family with you. Okay? Or you know
what, just kill these guys because
you're crazy, right?
All right. So, um what this tells us is
that yes,
um Odysius really loves his family and
he wants to be with his family because
he knows that if he goes to Troy, he'll
be gone for 20 years. That's 20 years um
that that he won't be able to see his
son Tammakus grow up. Okay. But at the
same time, this is the greatest war in
human history. Achilles is going. Eggman
is going. Does Odysius want to be really
want to be left out? Does he really want
to be the one guy is who is like a
coward who is like, you know what, I'm
just stay home. Right? The Greeks will
just laugh at him for the rest of his
life saying, "You're just a pussy."
right? You've been whipped by your
wife. Doesn't want to do that. So, it's
a conflict, right? So, what he does is
he comes up with a strategy that allows
the Greeks to see through it really
quickly and force him to go. So, he
doesn't have to bear any responsibility
for what he does. All right? And that is
a complexity of the human soul. That is
a complexity of our worldview.
All right?
So he goes to Troy and
he has to explain to himself why he's
there and he he knows he's going to be
away from home for 20 years, 10 years in
Troy, 10 years being lost at sea, right?
So his worldview is this.
Why am I here in Troy? Well, the first
reason is justice,
right? This is a just war because the
Trojan stole
Helen and therefore the Greeks must
avenge the honor of men. Okay. Second is
family.
[snorts] Helen should be with her
children. Helen should be with her
family in Sparta. We have to return her
to Sparta. How would I feel if Penplay
was stolen from me? I would want
everyone to go fight with me to get her
back as well, right? It's about family.
Okay. Now, third reason is legacy.
Yes, he will not see uh his son Kamakis
for 20 years. Therefore, he has to build
him a legacy that will carry him for the
rest of his life. If he is in Troy and
he wins this great war and he becomes
this great hero, then Tamakus himself
will be famous as a son of of Adysius.
People respect Tamakus. He wants to
build a legacy for his son. He wants to
tell his son this is this is how you
should live your life. you should live a
life of honor, of justice, of truth.
Okay, so these are the three reasons why
he goes to um Troy. And we have to
remember that this is all to justify his
conflict. Okay, there's a conflict.
There's a rupture in his soul. He needs
to mend it by explaining why he's doing
what he's doing. Okay? Because again,
he's abandoning his family for 20 years.
Okay? [snorts]
So um
what's going to happen is this this is
this is the worldview that Odysius has
when he enters Troy.
The problem starts when they win the
war. Okay? Because when they win the
warus
is forced to see that all these three
things
were wrong. Okay. He will discover that
this war was not about justice. It was
just about revenge and murder. It is
about family. It's about destroying
families because when you win this war,
you enslave the woman and kill the
husbands, right? That's destroying
families. [snorts] And it's not about
legacy because
you've destroyed the Trojan civilization
for no particular reason because Helen
Helen doesn't even want to go back to
Sparta. Okay? And this causes cognitive
dissonance
and this is what causes his PT
SD
okay or trauma. And so for in so the
Odyssey is his journey to repair his
soul so that he can go home. Okay, does
it does that make sense guys? That's
what the Odyssey is about. Okay, so what
we're going to do now is we are going to
um read certain sections. Okay, so this
is from the Iliad actually. Okay, this
is from the Iliad and
and so remember in book one of the
Iliad, Achilles and Manon have this
nasty fight where Achilles is like screw
you. You're a dog. I'm not going to
fight for you ever again. Eggman is like
screw you. I don't need you. Okay. But
in book two, Eggman recognizes that, oh,
there's actually a problem because
Achilles is the greatest warrior that we
have. And if Achilles uh doesn't want to
fight, then that's bad for morale. Okay,
we might actually even lose this war. So
Eggman on being stupid, he has this
stupid idea. And his stupid idea is
this. How can I rally my soldiers? How
can I galvanize them into action now
that Achilles has abandoned battlefield?
I know what I'll do. I'll tell them they
can go home. Huh? Reverse psychology,
guys. Right? Reverse psychology. Because
when I say you guys can go home,
every Greek WILL BE LIKE, "NO,
we came all the way to Troy to win glory
for you, Eggman. We're going to fight to
the death to ensure THAT YOU GET YOUR
GLORY, EGGMAN. WE DON'T WANT TO GO HOME.
DON'T MAKE US GO HOME. WE'RE GOING TO
FIGHT." OKAY, SO THAT'S the plan. And of
course, it backfires.
And when people hear, "Oh, we go home."
They all run away. And is like he now
has caught a dissonance. He's like what?
Huh? What? He doesn't understand what's
going on. Okay. And at this point in the
story, the war should be over because
all the Greeks just got went home. And
again, what happens is Adis will come
and save everyone because he will
recognize that just being stupid and he
will force all the Greeks to
uh return back to the post. Okay. All
right. So, Ivory, can can you read,
please? Testing his men.
>> Testing his men, but he only made the
spirit race inside their chests. All the
rank and file who never heard his plan.
And the whole assembly surged like big
like big waves at sea. The Aarian sea
when east and south winds drive it on,
blasting down in force from the clouds
of Father Zeus. Or when the west wind
shakes the deep sanding grain with with
hurricane gusts that flatten down the
stalks. So the mass assembly of troops
was was shaken now. They cried an alarm
and charged towards the ships and the
dust went whirling up from under rushing
feet as the men jostled back and forth
shouting orders. Grapple the ships. Drag
them down to the bright sea. Clean out
the launching channels. Shrill shouts
hitting the heavens. Fighters racing for
home knocking the blacks out underneath
the holes. Okay, so this just shows you
how stupid Eggman is because Eggman
thinks that his soldiers actually want
to fight this war, but all these
soldiers are homesick. They're sick of
this stupid war. They they don't know
why why they're in this war. Okay, so
the moment that Amanda says, "You guys
can go home." They're all like, "We
we're going to get home as soon as
possible." Okay, they missed their
wives. They missed your children. All
right, so Aphrodite and Hera are up up
in the sky. Okay, model Olympus. And
they they watch us and like, "Oh my god,
Ag Manon's going to lose us this war.
What a moron." And Hera says to Athena,
"Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. It's not
actually Hera and Aphrodite is Hera and
Athena because they're the ones who lost
the um contest to Aphrodite." Okay. But
Hera says to Athena, "YOU GET DOWN
THERE, MAN, and you stop this." Okay. So
Athena rushes down and he talks to
Adysius. Okay.
All right. Can you read it?
>> And now they might have won their
journey home. The men of Argos fighting
the will of fate. Yes, if her had not
alerted Athena. Inconceivable. Child of
Zeus, whose battle shield is thunder.
Tireless one. Athena. What is this the
way? All the archives flying home to
their fatherland. sailing over the seas
brought back, leaving Prime and all the
men of Troy a trophy to glory over.
Helen Argos, Helen, for whom so many
archives lost their lives in Troy, far
from native land. Go range the ranks of
Aken's arms and bronze. With your
winning words, hold back each man you
find. Don't let them haul their rolling
ships to sea. Okay.
>> The brighteyed goddess Palace lost no
time. Down. She flashed from the peaks
of Mount Olympus quickly reached the
ships and found Adys Adysius first. A
mastermind like Zeus still standing
fast. He had not laid a hand in his back
blackbenched hole. Such anguish racked
from his heart and fighting spirit. Now
close beside him the brighteyed goddess
stood and urged him on. Royal son of
>> Leartes Leartes Adysius great testician.
>> What is this the way?
>> Okay. So um so everyone's trying to go
home and you would think that Adysius
would be the first person to get on a
ship to go back to see his son and his
wife. Okay. But he's he's um standing
there. He's kind of confused. All right.
So he's like this doesn't make any sense
to me. Why would do this? But at the
same time, it sort of shows you that he
actually doesn't really want to go home,
right? Because if we want to go home,
he'd be home by now. Keep on going.
>> All you archives flying home to your
fatherland, tumbling into your or swept
ships, living prime, an old man of Troy,
a trophy to glory over.
>> Helen of Argos.
>> Helen of Argos. Helen for whom so many
archives lost their lives in Troy. Far
from native land. No, don't give up now.
Range the aen ranks with your winning
words. Hold back each man you find.
Don't let them haul the rolling ship to
sea. He knew the goddess's voice. He
[snorts] went on a run, fleeing off his
cape as Yuri picked it up. The herald of
of ethica always at his side. Coming
face to face with Atrites Agamemnon, he
relieved him of his father's royal
scepter. Its power can never die. and
grasping it tightly off, he strokes the
ships of Argam armed and bronze.
>> Okay, so he's now gonna sing singly save
the Greeks from losing this war. Okay,
so um
Athena, right? Athena is always part of
Odysius. It's part of his soul, right?
The intuition and his intuition tells
him something wrong here. I need to stop
this. Okay. Also [snorts] what? Look at
a manon. A manon is frozen. He he is so
distraught. He's shut down. Okay. His
brain has stopped working. It it's
frozen because this is not supposed to
happen. Right. When he says that you
guys can go home, he wanted everyone to
say no. We're going to stay and fight
for you. Eggman on. Right. So it's kind
of dissonance. It's so much cogn
dissonance that when um Odysius takes
the royal scepter,
everyone doesn't even notice the royal
scepter is part of his soul, right? It's
his legacy. It's what gives him
authority. He's the king of kings. And
this is just takes takes a crown from
his like, "No, I'm the king for now to
save this war." Okay? And it just shows
you how committed Odysius is to winning
this war. He really believes that this
war is about justice, about family,
about building a legacy for his son. So,
he refuses to lose this war. Right.
>> I I thought I
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry. Yeah. All right. All
right. So, um
but that's the Iliad. Okay. And again
what will happen is that Audacious will
win this war and he will win eternal
glory for himself with a strategim of
the Trojan horse. Right now [snorts] we
go
to the Odyssey and in the Odyssey
we don't actually meet Odysius for many
many books. Okay, it's only towards the
middle that we meet Odysius. In the
first few books it's it's a story of
Tamakus and his journey to find his
father. Okay. And when we meet Odysius,
he's a very different person from when
from the Iliad. Remember in the Iliad,
he is trying to win this war. He's very
energetic. He's galvanized. He's very
heroic. Okay? But when we see him in the
Odyssey, he's a changed person. In fact,
he's a broken person. So, what's
happening is that um Adis and his crew
try to go home and they get lost at sea.
They have many adventures and he gets
shipwrecked on an island. Um, and he's
and he becomes the sex toy. Okay,
literally a sex toy of a goddess named
Calypso. All right, so basically he's
getting raped every day uh at night and
then uh he goes to the beach and he
cries.
Okay. So, uh, and so, so, so he's he
he's a prisoner of Calypso for many
years and the gods Zeus, Athena, they
get together and and, and say, you know
what? We can't have this happen anymore.
Okay, Odysius needs to go home. So, they
send Hermes to tell Clip, "So, you have
to send Odysius home. The gods will it."
And Eclipse says, "Sure, why not?" Okay.
So, can you read?
>> With that, the powerful giant killer
sped away.
>> So, it's Hermes. Okay. So Hipper has
told Cypso, "You have to let this guy
go."
>> The queenly nymph sought out the great
Adysius. The commands of Zeus still
ranging in her ears and found him there
on headland, sitting still, weeping, his
eyes never dry, his sweet life flowing
away with the tears. He wept for his
foiled journey home, since then no
longer pleased.
>> So he's sitting, he's still, he's
weeping, his eyes never dry, and all
he's thinking about is the past. Okay,
this is clear signs of depression, PDST.
Okay, you want
>> in the night? True, he'd sleep with her
in the in the arching cave. He had no
choice. Unwilling lover alongside lover,
all too willing, but all his days he sit
on rocks and beaches, wrenching his
heart with sobs and groans and anguish,
gazing out over the barren sea through
blinding tears. Okay, so he's a broken
man. He's a very different person from
the Iliad. Okay, so now the question
then is why? What happened to him?
All right, so um KTO says to Adysius,
you know what? It's been great having a
sex toy, but the gods insist that you
have to go home. But you know what? You
can all you can choose to be my sex toy
for all eternity. I can make you
immortal, right? You can go home, but I
can make you immortal. and you'll be my
sex toy for all fraternity. Now, this is
is like that's a really nice offer. I I
really want to do this, but I need to go
home. Okay. So, he leaves and he gets an
island.
And on this island, he's given a ship to
go home. Okay. But before he goes home,
as a custom, they host a banquet for
him. Okay. And they really don't know
who he is. He They don't really know
he's Odysius. All right. So during the
banquet
um what's the tradition is have a bar
sing a great story. Okay. To sing a
story of great deeds. And of course he
sings about the Trojan War. Okay. So So
can you read um I I
>> Yeah. The strife between Adysius and
Achilles Pelius's son.
>> Okay. So So the B is singing about the
sword war. Okay.
How once at the gods flowing feast the
captains clashed in the savage war of
wards while Agamemnon lord of armies
rejoiced at heart that Achius's bravest
men were battling so for this was the
victory sign that Apollo prophecies at
his shrine in Pytho when Agamemnon
strode across the rocky threshold asking
the oracle for advice the start of the
tidal waves of ruin tumbling down on
Troy's and Aius's forces both at once
thanks the will of Zeus who rules the
world. That was the song the famous
Harper sang. But Adysius, clutching his
flaring sea blue cape in both powerful
hands, drew it over his head, and buried
his handsome face. Ashamed his host
might might see him shedding tears.
Whenever the wrath bard would pause in
the song, he'd lift the cape from his
head, wipe off his tears, and hoisting
his double-handed cup, pour it out to
the gods. But as but soon as the bard
would start again impelled to sing by
face's lords who reveled in his tail
again Adysius hid hid his face and wept.
Okay, so there's this great banquet and
uh the bar sing about the children war
and at this point you think this is like
hey that's me man he'd be very proud but
instead he cries and he cries okay this
again is trauma where the memories are
stirring pain in him so clearly
something happened during the Trojan war
that made him want to forget about it
that made him resent himself okay that
caused his soul or to be ruptured. All
right. All right. So,
um,
keep on going.
>> Adysius, master of many exploits. Praise
the singer. I respect you, Deathus, more
than any man alive. Surely the muse has
taught you, Zeus's daughter, or God
Apollo himself. How true to life, all
too true. You sing the Aens's fate. All
they did and suffered, all they soldered
through. As if you were the as if you
were there yourself or heard from one
who was. But come now, shift your
ground. Sing of the wooden horse Epus
built with Athenus's help. The cunning
trap that good that good Adysius brought
one day to the heights of Troy, filled
with fighting men who laid the city
waste. Sing that for me. True to life as
it deserves. And I will tell the world
at once how freely the muse gave you the
gods his own gift of song.
>> Okay. So he's feeling all this pain
because of memories of the war. But he
recognizes that if he's willing to go
home because remember he's on his
journey home. He needs to confront his
pain. He needs to admit his pain. Okay.
So now he's going to ask the bar to sing
the memory that he's most trying to
repress. He's trying to he he wants to
now focus on the children war and really
come to terms with his own trauma. Okay.
All right. So this so so let's let's see
what happens.
Sorry. Stern by the muse. The bard
launched out in a fine blaze of song.
Starting at just the point where the
main aen force setting their camps of
fire had boarded the or swept ships and
sailed for home. But famed Adysius's men
already crouched and hiding. In the
heart of Troy's assembly, dark in that
horse, the Trojans dragged themselves to
the city heights. Now it stood there
looming. And round its bulk the Trojan
sat debating, clashing days [music] on
end. Three plans split ranks. Either to
hack open the hollow vault with ruthless
bronze, or haul it up to the highest
ridge and pitch it down the cliffs, or
let it sand, a glorious offering made to
pacify the gods. And that that final
plan was bound to win the day. For Troy
was faded to perish once the city lodged
inside her walls the monstrous wooden
horse where the prime argu power lay in
weight with death and slaughter bearing
down on Troy.
>> Okay.
>> All right.
>> And he's saying how troops of aes broke
a broke from cover streaming out of the
horse's hollow flanks to plunder Troy.
He's saying how left and right they
ravaged the seep's city. Saying how
Adysius marched right up to
De Feebis's house like the god of war on
attack with thieard men lost.
>> Defabis isn't for pride. Okay. They want
to go kill the king. You want to go
>> there? He sang. Adysius fought the
grimst fight he had ever braved, but he
won through it last thanks to Athenus's
superhuman power. That was a song the
famous Harper sang. The great Adysius
melted into tears, running down from his
eyes wet his cheeks. As a woman weeps,
her arms flung around her darling
husband, a man who fell in battle,
fighting for town and townsmen, trying
to beat the day of doom from home and
children. Seeing the man go down, dying,
gasping for breath, she clings for dear
life, screams and shrills. But the
victors just behind her, digging spear
butts into her back and shoulders, drag
her off in bondage, yolked to hard
labor, pain, and the most heartbreaking
torment, waste her cheeks. So from
Adysius's eyes ran tears of heartbreak
now.
>> Okay. So now we know what happened.
Okay. All right. So what happened was
this. For 10 years, Odysius and the
Greeks were trying to defeat the Trojans
and they could not do it because the
Trojans were behind a walled city. So
Odysius prayed and prayed to Athena for
inspiration and then one day he had it.
The Trojan horse. Okay. So he sneaks in.
So he gets into the underbelly of the
Trojan horse along with other soldiers.
And then they get into the city and like
you know they're really scared, they're
really excited. Then they're able at
night to uh leave the Trojan horse and
then open the gates of Troy and they
stream in and they start to conquer the
city
and then Odysius, you know, he is
killing, okay, because it's war and he's
full of adrenaline. But then something
catches his eye, right? He strikes down
a soldier
and then the a woman comes crying.
and
she's traumatized at the sight of the
death of her husband.
And he's and this is traumatized by this
woman being traumatized because he came
to Troy
to save
the woman, right? He sees Penelope in
this woman. He says, "I came all this
way to make sure that Helen could be
safe of her husband." And now he just
recognized that I just killed someone's
husband. But not only that,
but
the Greeks come and they take her off to
be enslaved.
So he by winning this war has has
destroyed every single family in Troy.
He's caused the suffering of thousands
and thousands of women and children
and that is what he sees for the first
time. Okay. For the longest time he
believed that he was here to fight for
justice, to save families, to leave a
legacy for his son Tamakis. And now he
recognizes no
this is not a just war. I'm destroying
uh a civilization. This is not a war
about family. This this a war about
destroying families. And what am I what
legacy am I leaving my son?
How my son feel if he knows how I
destroyed families like ours?
And this causes trauma in him. It splits
his soul
and it drives him crazy basically. And
that's the conflict, the central
conflict in the Odyssey.
Having done so much evil, how can you go
home? How can you repair yourself? How
can you man your soul and repair your
worldview so that you can live for your
family? Okay.